red flag number 12 single mothers what's
wrong with a single mother maybe she
just made a mistake shouldn't we save
her that's what they want you to believe
don't they you're in a position where
you essentially choose to cuckold
yourself the reason why we are on this
Earth today is to scatter our seed and
pass on our DNA our name our Legacy and
all that sort of stuff and if you choose
to abandon an opportunity to do that to
raise another man's seed and provide for
them then you're essentially a cuck
there was an ERA where it was shameful
to be a single mother today with culture
and Society Hollywood and media it's
like you know it's celebrated you know
you go girl you're so strong and
independent and I don't think that it's
good for Society for culture or for the
world in general because I mean the
statistics are very clear children that
are incarcerated that's majority of them
come from single mother household
children that run away from home who are
great gang activity the absence of
fathers in a household is a terrible
thing for children some guys might say
well then I'll step up and I'll take
care of it okay well you can but you've
also cucked yourself now and now you're
not raising your own kids